[Music]
well things got a little interesting
yesterday colin coward floating a rumor
from the entertainment agent world that
russell wilson's wife sierra not happy
in seattle because it's not an
entertainment mecca would like to be in
new york which is an entertainment mecca
and coward proceeded to lay out the
possibility that maybe russell wilson
ends up being the next quarterback of
the new york giants and on the surface
i'm sure plenty of people said what are
you talking about how does that work
quarterbacks don't leave their teams
well russell wilson has himself set up
chris where his contract expires this
year his franchise tag for next year is
in excess of 30 million the year after
that it's in excess of 36 million and if
they tag him a third time it's 52
million and i was told last year around
april or may after some of these
quarterbacks were starting to sign
longer term deals and they were passing
up russell wilson on the annual average
there's some regret about the deal he
signed there's regret that he didn't do
the kirk cousins thing before kirk
cousins and go year to year under the
tag and and as of last year he wasn't
inclined to sign a long-term deal and
instead let it play out year to year and
if that's the case there's gonna be a
point where he's not the quarterback of
the seahawks yeah well it's certainly i
mean it
it could get interesting i guess that's
where i'll go with that he was very nice
to that football team in that
organization with the deal he took the
last time i mean he was just hitting the
prime of his career he was starting to
do really special things he had already
won a super bowl he played phenomenal in
the second super bowl that they lost i
know there's the interception at the end
of the game but really made a number of
big-time plays in that football game to
give that great defense a 10-point lead
in the fourth quarter against the new
england patriots and he was
yes very favorable to the team i mean a
four-year 87 million dollar deal uh that
is pretty nice of a guy and hey i i feel
like he's been disrespected at times in
seattle i feel like he gets disrespected
nationally at times he is without
question one of the three or four best
quarterbacks in football the last two or
three years and for some reason i feel
like when you talk to joe you know joe
football fan he doesn't always get put
in that conversation and i don't know if
that's because people think he's cheesy
or a dork in some way but i know on the
football field he's awesome and that's
all there is to it
his new money average at the time he did
the deal was 21.9 million just behind
aaron rodgers who was at 22. and the
problem is we saw guys like
andrew luck derek carr matthew stafford
kirk cousins matt ryan and aaron rodgers
again all out to the point where right
yeah eli manning's making in the same
ballpark but there's a lot of guys
making more who aren't anywhere close to
russell wilson and i think that's why
there's frustration and and one of these
true franchise quarterbacks chris is
going to say
well kirk cousins he's not one of the
top five guys and look at what he was
able to do we're going to do that too
and with the rules that protect
quarterbacks more than ever before and i
know the alex smith injury happened last
year that's a fluke quarterbacks are
protected more than ever before you can
get away with carrying the injury risk
and as long as wilson is able to say no
to the seahawks
and when they put those big numbers on
the table that are big but not as big as
they could be he can force his way to
the open market now that doesn't mean
the giants want him i don't know that
the giants want him i don't know that
the giants would pay him my point is
that russell wilson if he wants to can
ultimately end up on the open market
with years left in his prime and god
knows how much he would get if he would
be available to anyone who wants to sign
him if cousins got 28 last year that's
right wilson's getting 40. that's right
i mean yes wilson would be one of those
rare quarterbacks in football where i'd
go i'd give him just about anything
right now to make him the quarterback of
my football team he's in another
stratosphere from your quarterback in
minnesota kirk cousins and he's in
another stratosphere even from the derek
cars of the world right now he is
special i mean he really is and he's
doing all-time great special type things
when you look at his career numbers his
career quarterback rating his touchdown
interception ratio he's really in a lot
of ways and i understand there's people
up in seattle that don't love him and
maybe he's not always one of the guys
and like that type of way but for a
franchise he is like a prototypical
franchise quarterback who you want to be
the face of your franchise there's no
risk of what he does off the field he
handles himself like a professional on
the field in every interview whatever he
does he's all in on football at all
times and with all those things to your
point it speaks to big time money and
seattle's crazy if they don't try to do
something here real soon to get this
done
so many of those guys who are already
there in seattle resented him i don't
know whether it was jealousy i don't
know what it was but they did not like
him and the seahawks have been clearing
those guys out wouldn't that be the
ultimate irony they clear out all the
anti-russell guys and then russell says
see you later well it would and i think
and they see it they have to see it
coming yes the numbers are astronomical
yes they got to see it coming and to
like what you're just saying there
remember we talked about the super bowl
he found it refreshing that it was new
guys in the locker room with a new
challenge and a new feel for the team
and it's a new generation there in
seattle and he may be on a new team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports